[Music]
and don't be greedy news submitted by
lyrica from melbourne you never see
filthy Frank do it I watched him do it
disgusting and now you're gonna put it
in your [ __ ] mouth
No do it do it Asian shoppers are buying
up all the baby formula in Melbourne to
resell for a profit and shine the most
Asian estate I've ever heard of my
[ __ ] life you know what my friend
actually made a good amount of money in
the black market baby supply
international smuggling ring really but
he was he was explaining to me that so
in China Chinese people don't even trust
their own products oh this or their own
air yeah so they there's a lot of
millionaires out there there's like what
2 million millionaires or something like
that there's a ton cuz I mean there's
billions of people right and they don't
want to risk it they don't want to give
their kids like shitty products yeah
lead baby formula or whatever so they
trust uh you know Western products
because it trust the black market to get
the proper stuff yeah they trust it so
you know there's a limit and there's a
cap to like how much they can bring or
whatever so there's a there's a
smuggling ring that they just purchase
retail price like Western baby products
baby food formula all that stuff I
rather go with us automatically solid or
insane amounts out there that's funny
like when I was younger too Korean
people were like that too so my parents
would actually send like like [ __ ]
basic ass vitamins out because they
would like centrum you can't get sent
from the most basic of vitamins really
messed up and I'm pretty decidedly
prinstone and vitamin now and I'm
getting into the silver central have you
really half there well yeah it's a it's
a serious moneymaker it's a pretty big
industry even here though they have to
like
formulation because people would sell
less they sell it I think they jacking
it but I guess it's like a [ __ ] hot
commodity so it's kind of sad like
sending over drugs or something yeah
they go to prison for that and I go yeah
send some mean drugs over there but some
Enfamil yeah kick your ass for that
there's this video clip of these Asian
shoppers in Melbourne where they're just
taking all the baby formula because
apparently there's like a shortage going
on because of this in China
knowing oh because all the Chinese
people are selling it and sending it
back to their Chinese family so because
of that reason now like just the the
people that actually need the formula
are really upset because then they're
driving up prices and there's also a
shortage for people who actually need
the milk [ __ ] Chinese people ruin
every this is stirring up more racism
now I mean for an Australian to hate you
right because they're pretty nice over
there yeah you're stealing a baby
formula now they're all pissed that the
Chinese and that I'm surprised that
Chinese people even buy baby formula I
think they'll just give them like mung
beans and roots and [ __ ]
you know cuz we believe in like all the
the Eastern medicine [ __ ] yeah so I
don't even I didn't even think that
formula would be in the topic of
conversation you gonna see at this
grocery store they have like a shortage
of baby formula so then they're bringing
in this trolley that they're gonna
restock it and all these Asian shoppers
are just waiting there and then this
woman and like it's wrong like what you
guys are doing is wrong they're cheating
the system call the mainland Chinese
okay mainland I don't want to be
associated with those people I'm a
respectable human being
oh my god
it's over Enfamil that is crazy
at least I take the camera crazy I know
how to fix this oh yeah go back to the
titty don't necessary cap produce breast
milk and it's [ __ ] for some other
women it's [ __ ] hard but should I'm
glad I wasn't rise to rip off your child
has to die really yeah I didn't watch
wrong really no I had my infant no my
dad manufactured I just spit all over
myself and I got excited about now many
manufacturer not breastfeeding time for
milk he did yeah for laboratory when I
was growing up so I I got that I didn't
breastfeed your dad invented baby
formula he didn't invent it
he helped manufacture it i'm familia
back in the day but i funny that a
chinese person is telling a white person
about breaking the law and like privacy
i found this loophole can't get away
from me though every agent joke i just
go i don't smile why can't you be decent
i got the privacy i got a human right
okay yeah
I've never heard a Chinese fob say that
[ __ ] that is pretty good that's insane
we gather cheating the system because
they they've implemented all these
stores now they've implemented like a
limit per customer because of this and
they're saying that they're just coming
back with a beard so do they know what
they're using it for because I think
they're reselling it in China force yeah
I'm pretty sure I don't have that many
kids well they're sending it to their
family members because what if okay what
if they're like dirt dirt poor and then
they're sending it over there and that's
like their villages whole entire month's
income or what if they're turning a
profit and they aren't they are they're
making a lot of money on it I think each
of yeah the they could probably sell it
for hundreds of dollars that's you
selling it to millionaires and
billionaires that basically money's not
an issue for them they just want good
quality like products and safe products
so all that all that's going to them
does that mean that there's no Amazon in
China oh there is there is right it
seems like just be easier to buy I'm
gonna Tasha Solly Baba isn't it but like
they could totally rebuttal things you
know they can buy the you know and I
don't know I just think there's just no
trust in the system I see but what makes
me wonder like what the hell how come
they can is cuz like a lot of our
products life in from iPhones all that
yeah it's from China right and then
there's quality control there but baby
stuff I don't know it's so weird what if
it comes from China I'm just buying it
back I'm pretty sure it does like
everything's what that up who's got a
computer oh you do what babies do before
formula when the MA
couldn't that's all that's what house
about that one we just have to watch on
its founder eventually you just got it
you got to do it you have to do this you
have no choice
well I mean it is kind of natural
selection every time I watch a
documentary there is open titted lady
with a baby on it although Salma Hayek
wait what she was like in a village and
there was like a baby no it was a mother
who could not lactate or there was a few
and so she became the donor kid I
believe that's the scientific term she
breastfed another woman's baby yeah I
don't know yeah you what yeah it was
kind of odd yeah that's odd
yeah it's like you're not Mike you fed a
baby yeah like that wasn't your how do
you know you have what it takes to I
mean don't you have to I mean I know
naturally you do but nurses oh that's
what that infect nurses to just how did
that work did they get did they get
pregnant just so they could feed other
kids I don't think it is just for that
her stopped breastfeeding Oh cuz after
the way breast milk works so it's like
as long as their supply I wanted to hear
what he thought the process was yeah you
interrupted me TIFF I don't know nothing
oh my god I'm so sorry why did you hear
what you guys never happen just the one
time no I don't even remember so breast
milk works like as long as there's a
demand for it there is a supply in that
kind of sense so as long as something
sucking it and depleting its resources
yeah like if I wanted to nine years
after having Isaac like till this day I
could still have breasts are you serious
yeah there's women that's don't it was
you continued to us you're always having
the milk come out oh wait kind of like a
cow
you know Cal you gets milk right right
so as long as you got that now I'm with
you yeah
as long as you got someone going like
this then the cows gonna keep producing
milk so if you don't have a kid to suck
on you but if you just keep going like
this every day then you'll have a
continuous supply so you just can't
start out of the blue no you just can't
go hello no there was this dude in the
high school that could lactate from his
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] disgusting he was
in cross country cut this out it was me
but was he on steroids he was he was in
cross country and then one day he's a yo
you wanna see something like this and
then it didn't squirt it out but it was
he lactated from his [ __ ] [ __ ] Wow at
least he's proud of it Shane that's his
name I'm sorry I have to say did you
give him did you give him a nickname
were you one of those kids
no because lactaid Shane Shane on you
well I could I could have called him
like titty shake cuz I had titties any
shame yeah cuz he could probably roast
me even harder slice left it alone
cities change hope you guys enjoyed that
episode of JK news make sure to stay
connected because we're constantly
updating our social media so follow us
at JK films for Instagram and at JK
films for Twitter to watch more videos
click right over here